22 des 26 et assurances est touchée par
la grève des internes jacques barrot qui
déplore ce mouvement qualifié d'anti
réforme eric raoult peu présente en
conseil des ministres un programme
d'action pour favoriser l'intégration
des étrangers en situation régulière
une étude scientifique confirme le lien
tout à fait fort entre les crises
d'asthme et la pollution non inquiète ce
soir sera consacré à l'augmentation
inquiétante du nombre d'adolescents en
prison mais monsieur bonsoir à la veille
d'une nouvelle journée nationale de
manifestations
la grève des internes touche 22 des 26
centres hospitaliers universitaires
français avec la reprise aujourd'hui du
mouvement de grève au chu de rennes
pour se concilier l'opinion publique les
internes ont multiplié aujourd'hui des
opérations spectaculaires
par exemple des consultations gratuites
dans les rues de temps
de son côté alain juppé a envoyé sur le
terrain une quarantaine de
parlementaires en mission d'explication
reportage à strasbourg christine bost
patrie chum hr un amphi de médecine
comble pour un cours un peu particulier
sur les bancs inter des chefs de
clinique en grève
sur l'estrade presque un confrère
jacques richir médecin est aujourd'hui
surtout député udf du nord pas de calais
un émissaire du gouvernement venu faire
une explication de texte de la nouvelle
convention médicale contestée par les
internes
peut-être qu'il faut faire comme ça mais
les médecins ne peuvent pas faire ça
c'est l'épaule et dire si les politiques
va venir une fois plus soigneux et vieux
qu'il le dise clairement mené ki moon
avec la solution de facilité
aujourd'hui ce serait effectivement soit
la solution laxisme atp 15 20 ans comme
froid baisse des remboursements aux et
cotisations les français n'en veulent
plus
deux heures de dialogues aux tentatives
de dialogue dans un climat bon enfant où
lorsque deux logiques de la médecine
s'affrontent pour monsieur le député
mission accomplie l'objectif était
d'expliquer ce qui est sûr aujourd'hui
c'est que le problème majeur moi je
comprends que ça heurte un peu les
médecins croient qu'ils doivent
l'accepter c'est qu'on ne peut plus dans
la pratique médicale ne pas intégrer
en plus de l'aspect scientifique et
relationnel qui est fondamental la
dimension économique une dimension
économique qui signifie pour les
internes médecine à deux vitesses
là ça nous confirme quand même
parfaitement ce que le gouvernement veut
faire veut faire aux malades aux
patients aux assujettis sociaux c'est à
dire c'est à dire de leur imposer une
médecine comptable et non pas une
maîtrise médicalisée des dépenses de
santé en tête
tout revient à cela cette rencontre n'a
pas entamé les convictions des internes
strasbourgeois qui poursuivent la grève
et iront manifester demain à paris
jacques barrot je vous disais en titre
le ministre des affaires sociales a une
nouvelle fois déploré ces mouvements de
grève qualifiée d'anti réforme et d'anti
avenir en confirmant micro de rtl que
les conventions médicale serait à gré
dans les tout prochains jours selon les
statistiques de la cnam
le revenu annuel net c'est-à-dire les
charges du cabinet médical déduites est
d'environ 300 mille francs pour un
généraliste et de 500 mille francs pour
un spécialiste
c'est une moyenne bien sûr avec
d'énormes disparités la réforme de la
sécurité sociale prévoit tout un
dispositif de sanctions financières pour
les médecins trop prescripteurs
précisions laurent bailly les députés
ont prévenu pour la médecine de ville
la sécu ne devra pas avoir à rembourser
plus de 208 milliards cette année ça
correspond à une hausse moyenne de 1,3
pour cent des honoraires et des
prescriptions cet objectif et national
et s'il est globalement respecté il n'y
aura pas de sanction les médecins
pourront même obtenir l'autorisation
d'augmenter un peu leurs tarifs
en revanche si l'objectif est dépassée
la sécu mettra à l'amande les médecins
dans les régions dépensière karl
enveloppe de 200 8 milliards et ventilés
région par région par exemple en corse
les dépenses ne pourront pas dépasser
977 millions et le limousin est plafonné
à 2 milliards 800 millions
l'île de france est mieux loti compte
tenu de la démographie 26 milliards 700
millions à l'intérieur de chaque
enveloppe
on distingue les honoraires des
prescriptions si les médecins d'une
région dépensière perçoivent trop
d'honoraires ils devront reverser le
surplus intégralement à la sécu si celle
enveloppes des prescriptions qui
explosent leur amende sera limitée à 5%
du dépassement
parce que cet argent ne sera pas aller
dans leur poche dans tous les cas chaque
médecin de la région devra payer même
s'il a été vertueux seuls les jeunes
praticiens en cours d'installation
seront exonérés d'amande
mais pour éviter les injustices lamente
sera modulé en fonction de la taille du
dépassement du volume d'activité du coût
moyen par patient canton dépenses liées
aux soins lourds comme le traitement du
sida ou des cancers elles seront
naturellement prise en compte plus de
vingt mille personnes sont attendues
samedi à strasbourg ont manifesté contre
l'extrême droite
à l'occasion de la tenue dans cette
ville du congrès du front national
dès aujourd'hui la municipalité
socialiste a fait afficher 200 affiches
pour rappeler les valeurs démocratiques
face au message d'intolérance tandis que
les militants rpr procédé pour leur part
à une massive distribution de tracts
anti rpr aux portes anti uv anti front
national bien sûr au portage avis
tombèrent alain poirier
la pile toute chaude est arrivé cette
nuit de paris les militants rpr de
strasbourg sont les premiers à découvrir
le dernier argumentaire concocté par le
mouvement d'alain juppé il y a ceux qui
disent n'importe quoi proclame ce tract
résolument anti effet que les thèses du
front national sont des mails
epic yarn on a vu que la politique de
le statu quo de ne rien dire et de
laisser couler faisait augmenter le
front national
donc maintenant on le combat
définitivement un combat âpre à trois
jours d'un congrès du fn contre lequel
c'est d'abord la gauche qui mobilise un
combat difficile
il faut d'abord se défendre contre ceux
qui font de la surenchère la morale même
qui se jugent même
la mort à l'amérique je serai mieux
notable être nationale ensuite il faut
répondre à ceux qui mettent droite et
extrême droite dans le même peine il
faut pas présenter les
les imiter les hommes du commissaire la
france qui fait la france je pense pas
que la mer
disent que soient les
quoi c'était un peu le carré on a laissé
le front national s'accaparait de
certaines valeurs de la france en valeur
la république
il est malheureux qu'à l'heure actuelle
la droite ne peut plus parler de ces
valeurs qui sont les valeurs de défendre
la france d'être la nation française
jusqu'à présent toute la propagande du
rpr avait pour cible la boucle certains
militants du mal à changer d'adversaire
d'autres n'ont pas d'égal certains se
dit que finalement tiens est ce que le
pr nationale finalement nous piquent pas
un peu de mode terrain est ce que
finalement le front national la forte
roi des résolutions concrètes pour
toulouse santé plus proche d'un militant
du ps ou d'un militant du front national
imitant ps sens
3 et d'ottawa
samedi la droite organisera sa propre
manifestation dans les rues de
strasbourg le rpr mais aussi l'udf
veulent tenir toute leur place dans le
combat contre le parti de jean marie le
le parlement a définitivement adopté le
projet de loi sur l'immigration défendu
par jean louis debré la gauche a
confirmé son intention de saisir le
conseil constitutionnel
ce matin eric raoult tas a présenté en
conseil des ministres un programme
d'action pour favoriser l'intégration
des étrangers en situation régulière
bien sûr où il dit dans dans le
dispositif mis au point par eric raoult
ult l'intégration ça commence dès les
premiers jours passés en france en plus
des papiers les immigrés recevront un
contrat d'intégration en fait un guide
des droits et devoirs de chacun sous
forme de fiches
il contiendra aussi des renseignements
pratiques notamment sur l'apprentissage
du français
le but combler les lacunes dès l'arrivée
en france
en moyenne les immigrés ont droit à 200
heures de cours désormais ils pourront
avoir jusqu'à 500 heures pour bien
maîtriser la langue
autre priorité le logement en
particulier les foyers de travailleurs
20 au moins sont vétustes et surpeuplées
le gouvernement se donne cinq ans pour
les réhabiliter et 10 ans pour
restructurer l'ensemble du système
d'hébergement des travailleurs immigrés
dernier point noir de l'intégration les
procédures de naturalisation
l'administration met en moyenne deux ans
à examiner les dossiers des
et que le ministre veut ramener à un an
maximum et si le dossier est accepté la
remise du précieux document se fera lors
d'une cérémonie solennelle
un peu comme cela se pratique aux états
unis et chez nous en garde à vue ainsi
que son épouse l'ancien maire de cannes
en détention provisoire depuis
maintenant huit mois pour corruption et
entendu cette fois dans le cadre d'une
affaire immobilière mettant en cause une
filiale de la compagnie générale des
eaux
le groupe rpr du conseil régional d'île
de france a décidé d'entamer une
procédure d'exclusion à l'encontre de
claude annick tissot cette femme élue
elle même rpr déclare dans une interview
ce matin au parisien que le président du
conseil régional michel giraud avait lui
même demandé sa tête à jacques chirac
claude annick tissot avait mis en cause
les conditions de passation de certains
marchés publics nouvelle agacement
sérieux des belges contre les français
didier pineau valencienne le pdg du
groupe nwr aurait proposé à la justice
belge une transaction de l'ordre de 65
millions de francs et cela pour mettre
fin aux poursuites dont il fait l'objet
en à bruxelles depuis deux ans pour
escroquerie
démenti formel ce soir de l'intéressé
précision denis verdeilhan didier pineau
valencienne est un homme d'affaires
discret c'est en se cachant derrière un
journal que le pdg de schnyder avait
fait son entrée en prison en mai 94 à
bruxelles
c'est tout aussi discrètement qu'il a
proposé à la justice belge une sorte de
dessous de table de 66 millions de
francs en échange de quoi le dossier
instruit par le juge jean claude van
espen aurait purement et simplement été
enterré fini les poursuites pour faux
usage de faux abus de confiance et
escroquerie qui avait valu à pineau
valencienne 12 jours de prison et un
mandat d'arrêt international ce soir
pour le procureur du roi on n'achète pas
la justice belge d'examiner l'évolution
de la sphère sous l'angle d'une possible
transaction chose à quelle peine entendu
sans aucune hésitation il été répondu
par la négative il faut bien se rendre
compte que la justice pêche n'est pas à
vendre
justement qu'est ce qu'ils proposent est
exactement somme d'argent
c'est une transaction de l'ordre de 400
millions contre quoi
b contre une évolution de l' affaire qui
par cette transaction pourrait être
effectivement se terminer ce qui est en
fait juridiquement impossible c'est de
l'affabulation déclare ce soir didier
pineau valencienne qui n'écarte pas
néanmoins l'idée qu'une telle initiative
ait pu être prises en belgique à son
insu la justice belge de son côté étudie
quelles suites judiciaires données à ce
qui apparaît quand même comme un étrange
règlement à l'amiable
au québec que les enquêteurs attendent
avec impatience les résultats des
autopsies pratiquées sur les cinq corps
découverts samedi autopsie qui devrait
lever le voile sur plusieurs
incertitudes entourant ce drame lié à la
secte de l'ordre du temple solaire
notre envoyé spécial figues aso a
recueilli le témoignage d'une femme qui
a longuement fréquenté les membres de
cette secte
daniel a déménagé ici au village avec
son mari pour suivre les commandements
de l'ordre du temple solaire
ils ont tout vendu maisons et terrains
lui voulait être un élu elle a toujours
lutté s'est toujours méfié elle connaît
tous les rouages de la secte qu'elle a
fréquenté près de dix années
vous avez connu combien de personnes qui
sont passées par cette maison et qui ont
disparu depuis
officiellement les templiers des
agriculteurs bio leurs propriétés
immense en langue à la baule et puis ça
s'étend dès lors assez loin de ce côté
là son mari aurait pu faire partie des
suicides et de samedi dernier pour l
didier caisse sa femme et bruno klaus
était convaincu reste la grand mère il y
aurait là gramat
peut-être
vous ne la sentais pas ce suicide
non
pour l'accompagner chantal la compagnie
au canada
c'était sa seule fille mais il va avoir
une condition que les enfin pattes parce
qu'elle n'imagine pas elle non plus
accepter de partir en laissant les enfin
celle comment il interprétait le
transfert c'était quoi
c'était d'aller de partis au vert la
grande lumière dans ce village qui
devait être le dernier refuge avant
l'apocalypse l'ordre du temple est
partout même si bientôt la maison du
drame doit être rasé elle restera dans
les esprits
la cour d'appel d'aix en provence a
décidé aujourd'hui le renvoi devant la
cour d'assises du var des deux assassins
présumés du député affirme pia leurs
avocats auraient souhaité un complément
d'information en corse interpellation de
14 personnes des militants nationalistes
ou des sympathisants a soupçonné de
liens avec le milieu
en algérie les forces de sécurité
annonce avoir tué hier à alger le chef
de l'une des principaux groupes armés le
fida le front islamique pour le djihad
armé devant le sommet de l'onu à
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
réunis à lomé aujourd'hui le secrétaire
général de l'onu a exhorté les autorités
de kinshasa est née rebelles ivoiriens
se mettre sans tarder autour d'une table
de négociation pour la première fois
depuis le début du conflit en octobre
dernier des délégués du gouvernement
régulier et des rebelles se sont
retrouvés presque côte à côte dans la
capitale togolaise sur place dans l'est
du zaïre le chef de l'armée rebelle
laurent désiré kabila a répété qu'il
était hors de question pour lui
d'envisager un quelconque partage des
pouvoirs propositions faites la veille
par les dirigeants de la formation
politique du président mobutu la ville
de kisangani est en quelque sorte depuis
une semaine la capitale de la rébellion
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
martine laroche-joubert roger moore un
bureau de recrutement à kisangani
plusieurs centaines de jeunes virois
viennent s'inscrire
pour s'engager dans l'armée du chef
rebelle laurent désiré kabila une armée
toute auréolée de ses derniers succès
militaires des huttes
ils sont tous très jeunes entre 18 et 20
ans on nous a permis d'aller combattre
la chasse à parce que là bas il ya
beaucoup de militaires qui nous attend
là-bas qui chassent a aidé beaucoup de
mercenaires
je participe d'alarmé pour aller libérer
les amics ans le temps qui chassa est
partout sont en cause dans la dictature
de mobutu
c'est bien payé de s'engager bon même si
c'est le pas payer moi quand même il
faut que je m'engage centaines chaque
nuit ici très motivés surtout les
engager jusqu'où combattrai jusqu'au
avec l'ars en sautant des bureaux ne
trouble pas le calme du marché de
kisangani la tension qui précédait sa
chute aux mains des rebelles il ya dix
jours a totalement disparu
chacun ici pâques à ses occupations
habituelles en toute tranquillité juste
de l'autre côté du fleuve zaïre une
autre histoire
le camp de lula depuis quelques jours
arrivent des réfugiés rwandais et
burundais les marges depuis six mois
après le début des combats dans le sud
isère en octobre des revenus afin de les
fatiguer très très fier d'eux mêmes et
les chansons sont concrets employés ne
pouvons pas porter des souliers
nous n'avons plus rien à tout ce que
nous avions nous avons devant nous un
hommage car quand on les mange ça ça
fait mal d'art à la bouche c'est avec la
calomnie et quand on mange sans médias
les ils sont plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés à souhait sur
kisangani 06 81 millions ici mais les
rebelles de l'alliance ne veulent pas
d'eux il leur faut retourner au rwanda à
plus de six ans dans la tradition en
cisjordanie nouveaux affrontements très
violents entre militaires israéliens et
des jeunes palestiniens notamment à
ramallah une trentaine de blessés côté
palestinien touché par les balles en
caoutchouc depuis une semaine maintenant
ces manifestants protestent contre la
construction d'un nouveau quartier de
colonisation vie
dans la partie arabe de jérusalem est
l'émissaire américain arrive au demain
dans la région et yasser arafat a
écourté sa visite au bangladesh pour
rencontrer denis ross sur les quelques
cinquante huit mille détenus dans les
prisons françaises environ 600 aux moins
de 18 ans on recense de plus en plus
d'adolescents dans les prisons
françaises
phénomène inquiétant beaucoup de ces
jeunes sont pas car c'est vrai pour des
délits de plus en plus grave c'est le
thème de notre enquête menée ce soir par
valérie fourni et claude barnier une
adolescence derrière les barreaux 8h bol
d'air obligatoire le seul de la journée
ici pas de sonnerie pas de récré c'est
simplement la promenade du matin et les
surveillants les tmt à l'oeil en 15 ans
ou pas ils sont détenus attendant tous
leur jugement que je parle rarement à 10
heures après et il tourne en rond comme
leurs aînés de la cour d'à-côté marche
comme ça ce qu'on a toujours enseigné
comme ça on est couché on regarde la
télé respirez essoufflé quitte à nous
faire à fond souffler pour s'épuiser
quand je suis né des gens faibles comme
ça jusqu'à que fatigué après j'aime à
penser les juges bien sur d'infatigables
le fait tous les jours pratiquement tous
les combien de kilos raconte battant 52
x 30
ça dépend comment je suis enfant c'est
qu'il vient d'un quartier défavorisé où
règne la petite délinquance
un univers de violence j'ai mis le feu
dans l'ensemble c'était pour vous rendre
intéressant pour provoquer les les
surveillants vous dire c'était pour me
rendre intéressant deux autres copains
vous montrez que vous étiez un dur c'est
vrai c'est de la pub dior avec l'eau
dans le quartier mais envers la justice
on est mal vu elle est vue comme le
commander l'accord voyons des jeunes qui
qui disent moi j'ai fait de la prison et
qui assure pierre ils vont sur les
quartiers ouais moi quand j'étudiais on
a plusieurs qui disait ça je pensais
aussi moi je me dis ouais si je rentre
en prison c'est pas grave ça sera bien
et où le mannequin je regrette quand
même des tricheurs et pour être
surveillant dans un quartier de mineurs
il faut être volontaire pour leur tenir
tête sont peut-être plus exigeants ils
veulent absolument quitter la cellule
n'est pas étranger à ce que quand il ya
un problème c'est plus difficile le
résoudre avec des mineurs qui avec des
adultes
oui parce qu'avec des adultes on prend
des décisions qui sont
stricte et qui font part du également
alors qu'avec les mineurs on est obligé
de dialoguer parlementer expliqué donné
le pourquoi de sa décision
tu es content de lire ça prend expliqué
l'incarcération vécu comme une injustice
imposer des règles de vie en société
parfois avec une touche de couleur et
les doigts tachés peinture
ils retrouvent leurs gestes d'enfants
comme sevrés trop tôt pour qu'on
travaille là-dessus on apprend à grandir
seul ici donc il faut apprendre à vivre
tout seul donc d'agrandir adulte je
pense pas mais grandir plus vite
c'est sûr les grandir scène c'est facile
sans les parents n'ont pas toujours
c'est pas toujours facile parce que mon
âge on a quand même besoin de de ses
parents au delà du manque d'effectifs et
de l'isolément
c'est le pardon des adultes des parents
qui fait des fois c'est interdit de
mettre les couvertures boxe à vous et
moi c'est sûr que les parents pardonne
toujours mais c'est plus facile de
bordeaux n'est une petite métisse
l'humour aux métiers ce qui en avait
fait une grosse
oui on peut dire ça comme ça c'est une
affaire criminelle qui est tirée se
passe en cour d'assisses tant que si une
affaire grave trop grave
même pour un abus cki mineurs en prison
c'est un enfant avec
souvent des difficultés affectives avec
un comportement à l'extérieur qui n'ont
en fait moi j'ai parfois l'impression
qu'ils ne sont pas mal élevés n'ont pas
été au niveau
annie à égal les mineurs sont de plus en
plus nombreux à être incarcéré pour des
délits de plus en plus graves
le gouvernail de direction des boeing
737 il y en a actuellement environ 3000
en service dans le monde
présenterait un défaut de conception
informations données hier soir pour la
bbc citant un rapport du bureau
américain pour la sécurité du transport
selon lequel fut il faut être deux
catastrophes aériennes majeures ont été
provoqués par ce défaut de conception
démenti formel de boeing air france a
vérifié ses 43 boeing 737
aucune anomalie n'a été décelée sur les
empennages statistiques tout à fait
alarmistes de l'om est l'organisation
mondiale de la santé 250 mille femmes
meurent chaque année sur la planète d'un
cancer du col de l'utérus 2000 pour le
seul territoire français hors 90 % de
ces décès pourraient être évités si les
dépistages été correctement effectuée
et si la lecture des lames étaient plus
efficaces précisions avec ce reportage
de jean daniel flaysakier et daniel
lefebvre c'est actuellement la meilleure
arme contre le cancer
le frottis de dépistage des tumeurs du
col de l'utérus
un examen indolore qui permet d'étaler
sur une âme des milliers de cellules
il faudra ensuite dans cette multitude
aller rechercher la présence éventuelle
de cellules anormales ou même
franchement cancéreuses c'est pourquoi
l'examen de ces lames doit être
rigoureux car dépisté à temps une lésion
précancéreuse sera guéri à 100 % sans
compromettre la possibilité ultérieure
de grossesse mais lire une lame ce n'est
pas une sinécure même quand on est une
technicienne hautement entraînés
ça peut prendre
parfois dix minutes à un quart d'heure
dans une seule la wii si on a des
difficultés sur cette loi et les
difficultés on en rencontre sur 10% des
lames avec le risque de déclarer normal
un examen sur lequel il y aurait des
lésions
il faut donc absolument un deuxième avis
est avant tout celui du médecin
pathologiste la lecture des cas qui sont
pathologique c'est indispensable que le
diagnostic soit confirmée par deux
personnes différentes et la relecture de
femmes harris je pense que c'est
indispensable également parce que c'est
des femmes qui ont un risque beaucoup
plus élevé qu'une population normale de
re développer une nouvelle vision cette
nécessaire deuxième lecture n'est
toujours pas obligatoire en france les
pouvoirs publics en parle pour 98 au
plus tôt il ya même des laboratoires ou
en tout et pour tout une seule personne
lit les lames avec le risque de passer à
côté d'une anomalie dans les pays
nordiques où ce contrôle de qualité est
imposé et où les frottis sont faits tous
les trois ans il y a quatre fois moins
de cancers du col de l'utérus qu'en
france une étude scientifique vient de
confirmer ce que beaucoup de malades ou
de parents avaient déjà constaté
empiriquement le lien entre les crises
d'asthme et la pollution
reportage il m'arrive mais michel
levasseur 13 janvier 1997 paris s'efface
dans un nuage nauséabonds sur les écrans
de contrôle est très visible lui le pic
de pollution
une alerte de niveau 2 qui signifie
danger pour les asthmatiques qu'on
invite à rester chez eux pour longtemps
niée faux d'études sérieuses l'impact de
la pollution atmosphérique ne fait
désormais plus aucun doute
quand il ya des pics de pollution vous
vous sentez quelque chose que sagem ou
non il ne dit que ça q et l'odeur ce
n'est rien à côté des risques encourus
par le jeune asthmatiques de la simple
tout est la crise violente et cela tous
les jours
l'étude menée pendant six mois sur près
d'une centaine d'enfants parisiens âgés
de 7 à 15 ans démontre en effet que leur
état de santé et plus exactement les
caprices de la pollution ce qu'on peut
dire de temps avec cette étude là ce que
en tout cas ça augmente ça aggrave les
symptômes ça fait apparaissent des
symptômes salé multiplient c'est les
intensifie chez des enfants notamment
asthmatiques qui était donc atteints
antérieurement de cette affection
ça c'est incontestable incontestable
également le fait qu'il n'existe pas
pour les enfants asthmatiques un seuil
inoffensive de pollution
qu'en est il alors pour les autres les
jeunes citadins apparemment en bonne
santé
faux d'études il n'y a actuellement pas
de réponse à cette question dans notre
série où vit une époque formidable
saviez vous que les grandes villes
chinoises ne sont plus visibles depuis
les satellites d'observation en raison
de la pollution due à une consommation
considérable de charbon nos
correspondants permanents isabelle
bechler et tristan le braz ont suivi la
chaîne du charbon chinois de quoi causer
des frissons à zola et nilin datong est
un des hauts lieux minier de la chine
avec du charbon de plutôt bonne qualité
ici tout est noir et grades mouillé un
siècle après zola germinal et chinois
charbon ça me fait des économies j'ai
pas besoin d'en acheter pour me chauffer
la suite le poussier sont partout depuis
les satellites on ne voit plus des
villes comme date ont tellement
l'atmosphère est connu par la combustion
du charbon
tout est noir sauf les roues de la mine
qu'on veut bien nous montrer la plus
récente la plus propre
le charbon emploie 500 mille personnes
ici un habitant sur cinq
le bassin est fier de sa sécurité pas un
mort depuis 89 nous dit on et l'ouvrier
modèles sélectionnés pour nous est
heureux et pas fatigué quand ils
remontent
ce matin c'était rien j'ai travaillé sur
le ciel des galeries doit par ailleurs
j'ai passé quelques trous appareil
transportant des matériaux non il n'y a
pas eu problème
monsieur wang qui descend au foot depuis
29 ans pour lui le charbon est une
ressource d'avenir
d'ailleurs ses deux fils travaillait à
la mine le charbon
malgré la pollution qu'ils engendrent
sera incontournable pendant de longues
années encore en chine
c'est la source d'énergie la moins chère
et la plus facile à exploiter dans la
production augmente sans cesse
objectif de 1000 1 milliard 400 millions
de tonnes pour chauffé éclairé et faire
tourner le pays
quand nous parlons environnement et
pollution monsieur wang se veut
rassurant entre deux quintes de toux le
travailleront est plutôt sûr on ne prend
pas trop de risques le charbon et on
verse de l'eau pour empêcher la
poussière de voler on ne respire pas
trop comme les poumons de monsieur wang
l'atmosphère est malade des millions de
tonnes de méthane et de dioxyde de
soufre du au charbon mais la chine ne
cède pas 80% de ses centrales thermiques
sont alimentées au charbon et l'état
n'investit pas assez dans les
technologies propres
à l'aube de l'an 2000 cette chine sont
encore le 19e siècle pour doper le
réseau internet une seule solution non
point la révolution mais de bons vieux
missiles la recette est simple vous
prenez des ss 18 soviétique à la place
des têtes nucléaires
vous placez de mini satellite de
télécommunications la suite je laisse le
soin jean-claude allanic de la raconter
l'idée semble sortir d'un cd-rom
d'espionnage utiliser les missiles
nucléaires de l'ex urss pour lancer des
satellites
il fallait s'appeler il guette pour y
penser et comme le géant de
l'informatique ne fait pas les choses à
moitié c'est carrément 800 satellites
qui veut placer autour de la terre de
quoi donner le tournis aux astronautes
but de l'opération connecter le monde
entier à internet sans passer par le
téléphone
et pour lancer son armada de satellites
se servir de ces missiles ss 18 dont les
russes ne savent plus que faire
depuis les traités de désarmement à
missile qui sent un peu le souffre du
côté des fusées ariane titan a placé
autres lanceurs traditionnel de
satellites
évidemment ils guettent espère bien
faire des économies un lancement par dix
ils reviendraient quatre à cinq fois
moins cher par exemple qu avec ariane
chiffre contesté par les spécialistes
alors les difficultés bien sûr c'est
qu'il faut le remettre à l'état parce
que c'est les missiles qui sont
fabriqués depuis les années soixante dix
donc folie servir des silos il faut les
vérifier tout le problème est là
et combien ça coûte de vérifier l'état
d'un matériel qui reste est stocké par
rapport à fin avec un matériel neuf
c'est là qu'est la certitude l'avenir
dira si cette ou non un pari fou mais
les internautes ont déjà tranché en
caricaturant sur internet superbe il
guette le skieur français philippe billy
a battu tout à l'heure à vars le record
du monde du kilomètre lancé en
atteignant la vitesse de 240 3902
km/heure avec yann lavoix portrait de
billy the kid
attention chaude pistes pour ce genre
d'épreuve il vaut mieux sortir couvert
la combinaison est en latex
le casque lui protège la base du cou
pour limiter le risque de blessure
ensuite tout est une question de
concentration et de force dans les
cuisses pour maintenir une position
aérodynamique et les skis bien à plat il
faut du courage aussi
car le départ se situe à 2700 mètres
d'altitude et la descente fait un
kilomètre
le dénivelé 435 m le français philippe
billy 32 ans et sur sa piste avare il
est moniteur dans cette station
et vous l'avez compris avec 243 km heure
902 et il devient le nouveau recordman
du monde de la spécialité
mais l'effort est tellement intense que
philippe billy n'a plus assez de force
pour s'arrêter
je savais que j'aurais plus déjà
beaucoup pour tourner quoi qu'on va
arrêter et je suis parti tout droit
malgré la combinaison philippe billy a
eu la peau brûlée dans la chute
ce qui n'a fait qu'ajouter à
l'admiration que lui portent les
supporters bilan a amélioré de 2 km
heure l'ancien record rostropovitch a
choisi paris la ville qui l'avait
accueilli autant de son exil pour fêter
ses 70 ans à l'occasion d'un gala privé
au théâtre des champs elysées demain
soir en présence d'un parterre de chefs
d'états de souverains et de
personnalités l'islam rostropovitch a
été décoré par boris elstine pour ses
mérites devant la patrie le célèbre
violoncelliste réside à saint
pétersbourg où il s'implique beaucoup
dans la vie sociale comme l'ont constaté
louis carzou et dida lorsqu'il est de
passage à la philharmonie de saint
pétersbourg
slava rostropovitch est beaucoup plus
qu'un solistes prestigieux
son exil puissant retour au fil de
décennies marquées par les violentes
discordance de l'histoire russe
le maestro est désormais une référence
là
maman des jumeaux dans la vie
quotidienne il n'y a qu'à sa femme que
l'on peut dire des choses intimes
simplement avec des mots moi ce sont les
mêmes choses que je rencontrais plumer
mais c'est avec la musique
ce que raconte la musique de slava
rostropovitch lorsqu'il est de passage à
saint pétersbourg c'est l'amour qu'il
porte à ses enfants ceux de la clinique
pédiatrique l'institution abrite plus de
800 lits et ne reçoit plus d'argent
depuis un an
alors le maestro a créé une fondation
pour mobiliser moyens et notoriété au
service de ses enfants médicaments
matériels formation des personnels
ici l'on attend tous de la fondation
rostropovitch je crois qu'en russie
aujourd'hui l'urgence et la santé réseau
nés avec des malformations des
insuffisances
ça c'est tout ce que l'on trouve dans
l'eau avant de la filtrer avant c'est
cela que duvet les enfants d'ailleurs
comme tous les habitants de la vienne
sa fondation a déjà dépensé 5 millions
de francs simplement pour assurer de
l'eau claire aux enfants
en devenant fêter son anniversaire à
paris il a voulu montrer sa fidélité à
la ville qui avait accueilli l'artiste
ban il ya près de 20 ans mais
aujourd'hui comme à l'époque c'était la
russie que cela va rostropovitch dédie
la gravité et la mélancolie de son art
bonne nouvelle pour ses nombreux
admirateurs miss la france moto vici
effectuera au mois de mai en france une
grande tournée de concerts le film les
visiteurs a été le plus gros carton de
l'histoire du cinéma français avec 12
millions de spectateurs après bien sûr
l'intouchable grande vadrouille 17
millions de spectateurs
trois ans après les visiteurs reviennent
au tournage vient de commencer en
bourgogne avec muriel robin jean reno et
christian clavier
reportage exclusif stéphane haumant
emmanuel bec
c'était en l'an de grâce
11 123 lui si ce qu'a payé royer
violente man contre son cousin le duc de
normandie
cela fit rire la france entière en l'an
de grâce 1994
souvenez vous il y as jacquouille alias
christian clavier
le fidèle lac et du seigneur godefroy de
popa court compte de montmirail le front
jean reno 12 millions de spectateurs
plus tard les visiteurs sont de retour
une suite pour conter quoi cela mérite
d'en tester
raconter mon histoire confidentielles le
légendaire raffinement du moyen-âge
clavier a et ce qu'est l'histoire avec
le réalisateur jean marie poiré est
normal de le mettre à la question
comment se passent les retrouvailles
avec les visiteurs de jacquouille est
vraiment une fripouille
on n'en saura pas plus enfin pour
l'instant fidèle à sa tradition le film
mêle à nouveau le présent et le passé
beaucoup de passes et grâce à un budget
multiplié par quatre l'essentiel du film
se passera donc cette fois ci au moyen
âge aux côtés du séduisant jean reno
frénégonde sonné mais a changé de tête
muriel robin remplace valérie lemercier
et retrouve son âme d'enfant
mes prières sur l om déguisé dans
j'étais gamine et le vent les habits de
princesses et et c'est très très
malléable j'aime beaucoup ça je serai à
une reine très facilement donc c'est une
petite annonce sur je suis sereine je
veux bien je postule qu'est ce que cette
fois c'est vous tous qui est dans le
passé recherché jacquard c'est quelque
chose comme ça où nous verrons bien
ça ne veut pas savoir ses secrets sur le
mystérieux scénario du film est
décidément un saint graal inaccessible
seul atteindront ceux qui paieront leurs
places de cinéma dans quelques mois
voilà avant de vous souhaiter une
excellente soirée l écoute de nos
programmes avec ce soir un excellent
épisode de l'instit un mot de la
présélection du club de l'humour
politique avec entre autres cette
citation d'hervé de charette leader du
pp df
ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes un
parti charnière qu'il faut nous prendre
pour des cons dernier journal vers 00h30
en compagnie de philippe lefait demain
dans les 4 vérités à 7h50
gérard leclerc recevra l'écrivain
umberto eco
bon anniversaire à roch voisine 34 ans
aujourd'hui à thomas 30 ans dans un
instant la météo sophie davant grisaille
au nord soleil au sud
le dicton du jour à la sainte larissa je
m'offre un couscous demain 13h patrick
chêne sur le plaisir de vous retrouver à
20h excellente soirée merci